lake mead is at one of its lowest water
levels in history
and it's expected to hit a new record
low in a few weeks with the decline to
continue
madison kimbrough was at the lake today
where boaters are noticing the shoreline
transformation and having to change the
way they operate
as summer quickly approaches boaters are
out here enjoying the water here on lake
mead
but as you can see i'm standing on dry
land but just two weeks ago this entire
area was covered in water
major concerns on the lake with
decreasing water levels
it's horrible because we have to watch
out for all the rocks i'm a nervous
nelly
the lake's level dropped significantly
in the last 20 years
currently it's below 10 175 feet the
last time it was above sea level was in
2000
you know it makes it tough to drive your
boat around you got to worry about the
new
rocks and whatnot popping out of the
water and sand bars and stuff to that
extent gregg hauberger
chief of staff out on lake mead explains
why this is happening
yeah they're declining and that's due to
a lower snowpack in the colorado rockies
that combined with the hot dry weather
we've been experiencing we've had a
drought in
the western states for the past 20 years
and with it being memorial day weekend
there will be a lot of boaters
out here so it's important to know that
this ramp hemingway harbor will be
closed so do expect delays
reporting from lake mead madison
kimbrough 8 news now
now as for ramps that will be open
boulder harbor and carville bay will
have multiple
lanes open head out early to avoid the
rush and know that around five and six
boaters start returning to shore
we have a list of boat launch ramps
listed on our website eight newsnow dot
com